in my opinion 100 of anyone's money
should be invested in only one thing
which is increasing the earning capacity
that's it A friend of mine has a
daughter she's 17 years old she got a
job at a bowling alley she was making
minimum wage I think it was like 750
whatever he's like why don't you just uh
get a phlebotomy certification it's a
weekend and you immediately make 25 an
hour and so people think about that I'm
like guys it's 500 in two days it's a
weekend to get a phlebotomy
certification and forever she will have
three and a half extra earning capacity
for the rest of her life and so if you
take that same thousand dollars and put
it in the s p maybe it goes up ten
percent maybe it goes up 25 because
that's a crazy year right well cool you
have 250 extra you could have 250 extra
per week just by investing in that one
thing where you get a 50x return or 100x
return